in my hair mutton mitten ma'am
I have no idea what the sky stuff hey
what is going on YouTube now recently a
subscriber asked David I have a friend
and to be honest with you I don't want
to hurt his feelings but I feel like I
should let him know that he has a lot of
Bo coach so what should I do
oh man do I know what you talking bad
every single one of us out there has
this stinky ass friend for me Percy this
is what I would do I would tell that
[ __ ] that he smells like hot ass
on brick toast it's not because I'm
trying to be rude or I'm trying to be
funny I'm being the [ __ ] good friend
because I don't want him to go outside
in the world and kill all the plants for
this it's like if I was walking around
town and my friend knew that my zipper
was down on my dick was using and the
[ __ ] didn't say anything the whole time
because he was worried about my feeling
I would [ __ ] yeah you didn't let
anybody know what the [ __ ] is that look
at you now I'm in jail but for some damn
reason or another throughout the history
of time every single group of friends
has that one friend that smells like
chimp
ass so I'm gonna do this for your friend
and my friends and all those dudes out
there that smell I got to let you know
this it's been a while since I did one
of these baby but you already know what
it is
LGI baby let's get a let's go you
[ __ ] stink how the [ __ ] is it that
throughout your whole life that you have
existed that you cannot smell yourself
the reason why women do not want to
touch you is because when they get near
you their hair falls how you know every
time we go to a baseball game and
they're like hey everybody let's do the
way there's a reason why I always keep
your hands down you never thought it was
funny that every time you put one of
your friends in a headlock they would
knock out in a half a second [ __ ]
that's not because you're strong is cuz
your Bo is stronger as your friend this
is how I'm gonna help you I'm gonna
teach you every
that's in your bathroom or things that
should be in your bathroom to help you
smell like a normal human being number
one if you have running water in your
house use it you might see the thing
that's a handle like this that turns
this way that thing my friend brings
water to wash your stink ass tip number
two don't just let the water hit your
body you have to do something with it
some of you crusty [ __ ] out there
probably shower like this
[Music]
you might as well just walk out but-
when it rains and you think you're doing
the same thing have you ever thought
about investing into one of these scale
with a manatee it scrubs dead skin off
your body you know the [ __ ] that every
time you scratch a flake it all over our
dinner table but wait you just don't put
water on it and just shash yeah you put
soap in it you [ __ ] filthy animal
them away downtown so comes in many
different ways bar form sometimes it'll
come out into a gel or liquid form where
you pump it into this loofah it'll cause
suds yes and you just don't put it on
the surface here you'll go on your balls
your back your butt your legs because
that's where the source of death is
coming from some of you dumb [ __ ] say
certain things like this that's
something you only need to do maybe once
a month
no [ __ ] do that [ __ ] every day
tip number three you have something
called shampoo I've heard some of you
say this I can't wash my head on a
regular basis it's gonna get rid of my
natural oils and to that I say [ __ ]
nobody's asking you to [ __ ] shampoo
your hair every day on a regular basis
[ __ ] but you gotta do it more
often than not when we thought about
natural oils [ __ ] would you a
sponsor athlete for Crisco mother [ __ ]
with your greasy ass [ __ ] head
looking like a fire hazard what the [ __ ]
you think every time we go Kevin I get
your last 10 feet away from a campfire
and last but not least face wash now I
know what you're thinking that face wash
looks mighty girly David well how about
this
don't worry about my [ __ ] clean face
your dirty little pimply [ __ ] ain't
nobody give a [ __ ] what's up look like
[ __ ] they got to smell nice do the job
and clean my face and Asian people know
what's up look at this cute ass little
peach washing your face by the way my
friends is not an option you should do
it all the time and because this is
basic on another video I'll teach you
[ __ ] how to keep your face moisturizing
your elbows a little less ashy because
some of you [ __ ] haven't
figured out what lotion is yet but hey
that's just some friendly advice from
one fat [ __ ] that smells really nice hey
o matic a thermometer one is in the
phenomena to one or two friends
[ __ ] you speak English cousin
you speak English cut that was [ __ ] by
a donkey what